when i found out our next speaker was
from nasa
i was really excited to have a talk
about space then he said he's going to
talk about people
not space but that's okay i'm still
interested in people too
and way back in 1977 our speaker was
15 years old and his friend came over
and he had an extra ticket to go see two
bands
but our speaker's dad really wasn't in
the mood so he wasn't going to push it
so he asked his friend who the bands
were and the friend said
ac dc and journey and our speaker
didn't know who those bands were so he
said okay no big deal
now he knows better everyone please
welcome david
so what i want to do today is talk a
little bit about it and i appreciate
jared the the introduction and it was
definitely
um very interesting
that time in my life when i had to make
decisions and
unfortunately that time i made the wrong
decision but hopefully over the years
i've made better decisions
and and when we look at decisions and
we're looking at trying to figure out
our
our ability to to look at our skill sets
across nasa uh i was asked to take a
look at how we're developing our skill
sets
across our information across our
different things so let me give a little
bit of an idea of what we're trying to
do in developing a knowledge graph
across nasa
let me start here so first thing as we
take a look at nasa here should kind of
give you an idea of
where we are and what we do we've got
various different centers
uh 10 different centers another six or
seven facilities
and we also have a research lab that
kind of floats to a couple hundred miles
buzzy above the earth
where we have to identify our workers
our abilities and our different skills
and we've got a lot of different
programs and projects going on
of course now we've got a big mission
underway of trying to get back to the
moon and on to mars and we have to
identify the skill sets across the
organizations and each of these centers
do different things
we have research centers that focus on
on medical issues we've got other
research centers that look at
propulsion or heliophysics or planetary
science and climate control
we also have our engineering areas like
johnson space center and kennedy kennedy
space center that work
on actually getting our human
exploration so there's a lot of skill
sets are
strewn across all across the united
states
and across different programs and each
center does different things but we need
to really need to identify
where they're all located and how we can
how we can better utilize these skill
sets
so as we start thinking about this and i
was brought into
human capital about a year ago to take a
look at this i first had to understand
what our architecture looked like
and as we take a look at analytical
architecture when i first started this
organism in this organization
we had the far left and the far right
and that was about it we had some some
ways of acquiring data and we had ways
of showing data but nothing in the
middle so over the last uh
six to eight months i've been trying to
slowly integrate various tool sets into
our pipeline
to allow us to connect to our our skill
sets to allow us to
connect to our data actually to identify
our skill sets and do various things
across human capital with people
analytics
but one of the major problems i had or
not problems but an issue or concern was
that we had everybody doing
doing different things we had various
skill sets
across even our employees do an analysis
some people use python some people use
ruby other people use
r so i wanted to try to find platforms
and connections of how we can do all of
this together so the example i'm going
to show here today
is really how we can combine
not only various technologies uh to do
this analysis but how to do this
to in in a way seamlessly to be able to
share data across internally that can
help us across the agency
uh so we'll we'll see how i connect from
different data sources like a neo4j
graph database
into utilizing both python and r
through some machine learning and
eventually to a visualization aspect of
that
so how do we create knowledge graphs
first of all a knowledge graph is
basically an understanding of a
particular domain with various
relationships across this domain we ask
different questions we define the model
we do some analysis and the various tool
sets that i'm using here today are going
to be neo4j
rnr studio and python along with various
algorithms
with inside both of these packages you
can find my
code for this at that github repository
and be able to update and actually do
some of this work on your
own because we have some open source
data that's available with that
why are we doing this well and when
gartner research
surveyed various different hr executives
the top two things in two different
surveys was
critical skills building critical skills
and competencies as well as the
emergence of new tasks and
responsibilities for employees
so those are the type of things that
we're really looking for not only at
nasa but it turns out that most of the
industry is also trying to figure out
ways of
improving their skills primarily because
of the new the way things are going on
now with the covet situation and new
ways of doing business
so this has really come to the forefront
and it's really a way of looking at not
only
nasa skills but across the industry
skills
so what can you do with these things
there's a lot of different things we've
looked at and what we can analyze with
and one of the things is how do we
where's our our actual skills across the
workforce can we actually identify what
project what program what theme or
mission
it actually has these type of groups of
skills and it turns out we can to a
degree
you know can we identify adjacent skills
if somebody knows cypher do they also
know sql or python and r
how can we do some kind of adjacencies
on that and if i want to change careers
what should i learn
as we start infusing more things into
our knowledge graph we can add things
such as training information curriculum
objectives of that to identify skills
and knowledge that may be attained in
that
but now let's try to put this all
together we can start with a
current database that's currently out
there called o net by the department of
labor
that actually has a little over a
thousand occupations already developed
into a database
uh or that they've looked at over the
last 60 or 70 years they've created this
and each of these databases has some
elements those elements are made up of
skills
knowledge tasks and abilities and the
data model looks something like this
so on the far left hand side you have an
ownnet database that we
pulled down from the department of labor
and we can break this down into a graph
model
and in the graph model the circles here
represent nodes or entities
and the lines represent relationships
across those nodes or entities
so the elements that make up an
occupation are broken down into things
such as tool use work activities
abilities knowledge tasks skills etc
those can be found in occupations well
that's just part of the database the
knowledge
graph can be expanded to include nasty
information such as
what opm series and that in itself is
just the
our nasa government code or our
government code as to what kind of
occupation it is
but that could also be related to an
employee and how do we get information
from the employee well we've taken
information from the employee's position
description
run some similarity analysis between the
persistent description and the
elements within the ownet database to
try to identify which of those elements
may also be found in an employee
and build that back into the graph as
well as providing additional information
about where they charge to
to find out how we can might be able to
see what skills his employee has
and how they're applying it to different
programs and projects
that kind of gives you a little
semblance of a knowledge graph in itself
and how we created this random graph
model to to look at our skills
but how do we build this how do we
actually do something like this
so i developed this kind of a knowledge
graph model of what we're trying to do
just kind of
real quickly showcase how this all works
together
on the left hand side you have
occupations again from the own net that
we
we extract the different case sets the
knowledge skills abilities and tasks
those we use to create a vocabulary
that will train a doctor vec model that
will be stored and allow us to to
utilize that and infer against the
employee's description
on the right hand side we have these
employees and from the employees we have
different information the job
descriptions
performance evaluation resumes the cvs
and training
and from that we can we can use that
information to infer against the doctor
x model and maybe pull out
various uh skills knowledge and elements
that may be found
in that database add all that together
in a graph database put it all together
run some graph algorithms against that
and start to identify different things
as skill gaps career paths
succession planning and maybe a
strategic alignment model those are the
types of things you can do with the
graph model but first we've got to get
that all in together
and i'm going to show you really quick
how we did that and how you might be
able to look at that and
pull out some information from this
graph model
so we first start off here's where i
start combining the world of python and
r and everything just together
with the help of some interns and some
different and different folks in my in
my team
we were able to create a python script
that when run
connects back to your neo4j graph
database
and and actually pulls the the own
database directly from the website
runs some algorithms creates the
constraints uh inserts the graph
database
uh makes the relationships and within a
matter of of about
20 minutes roughly depending again on
your resources and what you have
you come up with something like this in
the graph database
now of course yeah this looks a little
bit uh this it looks a little
weird and wild and can but you know not
like the graph model i showed you
earlier
but trust me it has all the information
in the graph model
everything here in the colored are the
are the elements that came from the
occupation on the on the two
nodes on the far right hand side of the
occupations the in the elements inside
of that the interest the abilities the
tasks are all related back to the
occupation
but you also start seeing other patterns
and other connections here
on the left hand side over here towards
the towards the bottom left you see
that's the actual charge codes and where
somebody's paying to
and we can start seeing those
relationships which will eventually get
associated back to an employee
and back to an occupation and i'll show
how that works and give you an example
of what that looks like in a little bit
so now that we have the graph database
we've got to create our dr vec functions
in order for us to be able to uh infer
against the employees of
information so here are some of the
functions that are that we've created to
clean the test create the model
and i'll expand on a few here to show
exactly what we're doing to get this
information
but we're combining i think what i want
to really want to get across is we're
combining
various uh technologies uh here we're
combining
some python scripts connecting back to a
neo4j graph database
and then eventually use some r scripts
to do some more major cleaning
um because then it's an r primary are
you sure i'm more
familiar with doing a lot of the uh
analysis in r
than python so which having to mix these
together showing how
as a team we can work together with
various technologies
so in order to create the model the
first thing we need to do is actually
build a vocabulary for that model
and we could we use a cipher query
that we store into a into a python
script here
to connect to the graph database and
pull that information out of the
out of the actual graph database so what
we're doing here
in in simplest terms is with this query
i'm pulling out all the information
about all the elements
associated to occupations and i'm using
that as the vocabulary
to build my model my doctor vect model
using the gensim package
within python and i'm looking at a
vector size down at the bottom you can
see a vector size of about 200 using the
skip gram
model with the minimum account of at
least two for the words
um using 50 epochs and a window of four
across the the words themselves to look
at the context of the words
and how they may be related to each
other so once i've built
the model i can then go back to r
where i need to do some first some some
pre-cleaning and some
and some ins uh changing of my employee
information
it's very you know one of the things
that always gets me all the time is how
we've been around for um 50 plus years
here at nasa and we've got data all over
the place and we've
used so many different ways of
structuring our data
we're still struggling how to get our
data governance in play to make sure
that we we
share information alike even within our
employee information
some information in here in this
particular case what you see with the
epds series
up here at the top is our codes for our
occupations
come in three different formats uh and
so i needed to make sure i can relate
them back together so i'm here i'm
combining the coach
and adding some information and notice
that it all looks the same
across all the different platforms then
i'm creating here
these the drveck or the document
sections for when i'm going to infer
back into the drvek model
so in here i'm tokenizing the documents
the position descriptions of the
employees
into sentences and i'm going to use the
sentences as the individual documents so
that i can infer those
back to a particular skill or knowledge
or
task or something within the owned
database
once i've done that i've saved that back
into a csv
so that i can then utilize that back
into the python scripts to
pull that infer that that information
back into the doctofx model
so in this particular case the top uh
function here
is basically tagging the position
description information
um tokenizing and tagging that so i can
utilize that
in the drvec model so each of those
words are tagged with an appropriate
sentence id
that allows me to use that information
to figure out how to how to
find the similar elements
the the knowledge skills or abilities
with that may relate back to the
position description
the the bottom script there and i just
noticed that that is named
topped uh 10 similar but if you really
look i'm only pulling up the top three
um we've played around with with how
many uh different similarities
uh scores we're pulling out so this
function basically takes that uh
uh infers that that the
l those tag documents from the position
description against the dr beck model
and finds the top three most similar
elements uh within that information
and then it returns back to me a uh a
basically a data frame that looks
something like this it's got my
physician description which is the id
for that sentence so i and and the
numbers basically represent the
you you pick which is the individual id
of an employee
the position a description number um
the the 303 in this top line is actually
the opm or the job code for that
individual
and then the one represents the the
sentence that it came from so then i can
i connect those relationships back to
that individual sentence
and here are the top three similar
elements
found as you can see within this this
one sentence
it's saying that with the 46
similarities close to a basic skill
entry requirement
of active listening uh it's also 45
close to a competency of negotiation and
44
close to a work style of stress
tolerance
i guess from uh if you think about it if
you're doing a lot of negotiation and
really listening you've got to have some
good tolerance for stress when you're
trying to do a lot of that work
but you'll see that this is how it's
trying to pull up those top three things
but it's not very easy for me to utilize
this information
uh to put it back into the neo4j graph
database
so i i go back to r where i read that
information
in i do some some i'm cleaning up some
rearranging some some separating of the
the position input number so that i can
uh spread that across and actually
identify these things
and once i do all of this i then come
back to a formatted output that
has separated all and allows me to see
the various labels
for the node entities of knowledge of
the titles the similarities and how they
may be represented back to a particular
sentence
within a employee's position description
all of this information will get placed
back into
the neo4j graph database i'll utilize
scripts here
to make the relationship between the
employee and the individual
node or knowledge or element node
whether it be knowledge skills abilities
and make that relationship back
utilizing the weight of similarities so
that we can try to
play around a little bit with that to
see how close they may be related
once all of that information back is put
into the graph database
i can start doing visualizations like
this out of the graph database
so in this particular case i'm looking
at an individual here and actually
myself
david i pulled this out of the node and
i have
associated all these various skills and
elements that were found within my
position description
that are also related to my current
occupation computer and information
research scientists
so all of that is we're showing how
related they are and
what the most important elements or
skills are found in that occupation as
well as in my current position
description
but now i can also associate back to
what uh where i charge to not only what
what program or project but what mission
and what theme and all the way back down
to our official
division that i may be charging to uh so
now as a
manager i can ask the question what
skills do i have in my particular
program or project or theme
by aggregating all of this information
back up the length of the chain
and identifying where my skills are
associated so it allows me to
ask a lot of questions like do i have
the right skills in my my program
what skills are lacking what skills are
missing allowing me to start
really trying to identify what i need to
do to change and maybe improve upon my
organization
but also help find individuals that may
be useful for my program
so how do i do that i now turn to
um going back directly into neo4j with
some different cipher queries
and if you're not familiar with graph
databases the cipher query is the
equivalent of a sql query
within a regular relational database
model
that can be that can pull out
information so in this particular case
after i've
ingested all that information i've taken
the information from ownnet
i've i've added some more information
from my employee information utilizing
this drvec model and put that all into a
graph database
i can start asking questions such as
this as to what rank skills by
occupation
one of the information pieces that comes
out of onit is that they
do an assessment of all the skills of
how important they are to a particular
job
so in this case i just pulled out the
information for a computer and
information research scientists
and looked at a few of the basic skills
and the importance level and here the
the most important level the most
important thing
that was identified by onnet was that
understanding written sentences
um was the most important skill for
research uh in computer information
research scientists
even higher than using mathematics to
solve problems but even if you look at
the top five skills here are more about
communication
and giving attention than it is about
actually doing mathematics and solving
problems for your basic skills
uh so it shows how important this
communication is across
um any occupation but there's more
things we can do with this type of
information
what if i wanted to do a career change
what if i'm a management analyst
somebody that that's doing just a
research report or or
and and i want to see i really want to
get into maybe a
business intelligence and doing some
more things like
that utilizing this query i can pull out
information about
management analysts and other
occupations that may be similar
to management analysts based on the
the number of nodes that intersect
across those so the number of
skills or knowledge intersecting across
management and other
i.t type skills and as you can see uh
business intelligent analyst is about 46
similar to a management analyst so it
tells me
what skills are similar what knowledge
is similar but it also tells me what
skills and knowledge i need to gain
in order to retain my my goal of
becoming maybe a business intelligence
analyst or some other career
so it allows us to start seeing how we
can move people around
in different locations or if i'm a
project manager and i need a business
intelligence analyst i can go research
my employees and find out who's close
may have an interest that i can upskill
to make them a business intelligent
analysts
there's a lot of different things we can
do as we move through this
um and speaking as far as looking at
employees one of the things we can do
here is find
similar employees if i have a program or
project and i and i need particular
skills
i can utilize a query like this to find
employees that match those skills and
knowledge
for my program and project and start
reaching out to them to see if they're
available to join my program or project
at that time
so another way we can identify skills
and utilize
these things across the organization
last thing i want to show here really
quick is as you try to combine all this
together
how do we start visualizing these things
this kudos goes out to my current intern
madison gibson who
who created this little dash app that
we're going to put back into our rconext
server to be able to utilize it but i'll
show this video really quick here which
shows it connecting to the neo4j graph
database
you start putting in information that
you may be looking for
and and here again we're looking for
computer and information research
scientists
and it clicks similar occupations and
computer and information research
scientists that can be found
within the organization and how similar
they are based on
the nodes they share the the skills the
knowledge the the interest and things
that they're shared across the
occupation
i could do this we could do this for
employees and various different things
also
but for privacy reasons this is the only
thing i could show
but those are ways that we can share
information across so as you can see
across this thing we've done a lot of
work to this to try to develop skills
across the organization
but there's still more to come we can do
things as recommendation engines for
people that are looking for
maybe small projects to work on i have a
certain skill what jobs are available or
vice versa
can i find experts in the field also as
we add training information we can
develop training
training plans i want to get to a
particular career goal this is what i
want to do
what training do i need to take based on
on how those those
training objectives inform or add to
the skills that i want to learn and also
help us outline career paths
so in this 20 minutes or so what i
really wanted to show is how we utilize
various technologies to try to develop
these skills
combine them together to be able to
share across the organization ways
of sharing information building a past
what what we currently have
in order to be utilized all our
information so hopefully i stuck the
landing here
and you're welcome to to reach out to me
or to my intern current intern
on some of this work we've done if you
have any questions i'd be more than
happy to connect it
and answer questions offline at this
point i want to thank everybody for
their time
and i pass it back to jared thank you
very much david
i wonder how much of that you use on
astronauts
coming up next is our time to do